und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka abend
für die europäischen staats und
regierungschefs die sich heute und
morgen wieder zu einem video gipfel
zusammenschalten grund sich vielleicht
ein blick nach israel als blicke die
zukunft gewissermaßen nicht nur das in
israel inzwischen schon in möbelhäusern
oder kneipen geimpft wird letzteres in
verbindung mit freibier
außerdem bekommen die impfte einen pass
der ihnen zugang zu schwimmbädern kinos
und so weiter eröffnet und er soll auf
freies reisen ermöglichen
in europa ist das umstritten aber lässt
sich eine solche entwicklung überhaupt
aufhalten und was wird das für den
europäischen grenzverkehr bedeuten
auch darüber haben die europäer heute
diskutiert die meinungen gehen da wie
gesagt noch auseinander
einig ist man sich hingegen das jetzt
vor allem erstmal das impfen in europa
vorangetrieben werden muss aus brüssel
stefan leifert es ist kein zufall dass
kurz vor dem eu-gipfel der für industrie
zuständige eu-kommissar dem kaiser
impfstoffwerk einen besuch abstattet die
eu-kommission will jetzt wirklich keinen
zweifel mehr aufkommen lassen dass sie
verstanden hat europas impfkampagne soll
endlich eine erfolgsgeschichte werden
wie weit sie noch davon entfernt ist
weiß vor allem sie die
kommissionspräsidentin verspricht aufs
tempo zu drücken
to continue increasing jetzt weiter das
tempo unserer bemühungen zu erhöhen
müssen alle eine rolle spielen deswegen
arbeiten wir mit den unternehmen
zusammen um die produktion zu
beschleunigen und um uns mit den
flaschenhälsen zu beschäftigen
wir wollen mehr berechenbarkeit und
transparenz um sicherzustellen dass die
pharmaunternehmen ihre zusagen einhalten
brüssels kalender wollte es dass sich
zeitgleich zum gipfel die chefs der
impfstoff firmen eine anhörung des
europaparlaments stellten auch sie
versprachen ihre zusagen zu halten
der eu gipfel tagte heute wieder im
videomodus grenzen musste dafür niemand
überqueren
doch es sind die bilder von europas
grenzen die die regierungschefs heute
beschäftigten es wird wieder
kontrolliert wie hier an der deutsch
tschechischen grenze 9000 reisende
wurden in den letzten tagen wieder
zurückgeschickt heute kündigt das
saarland an seine einreisebestimmungen
zu verschärfen an der grenze zum
französischen verwaltungsbezirk modell
ist künftig ein negativer pcr test nötig
von dänemark bis spanien von belgien bis
ungarn zehn eu staaten führen gerade
grenzkontrollen durch deutschland
erhielt diese woche dafür einen
beschwerdebrief aus brüssel
ich habe für deutschland erklärt dass
wir uns in bestimmten fällen
und da sind wir nicht die einzigen
gezwungen sehen auch bestimmte
beschränkungen einzuführen wenn es
entweder hoch incidents gebiete oder
mutations gebiete gibt auf den tisch
auch noch ein vorstoß aus österreich ein
digitaler impfpass soll allen die
geimpfte oder nachweislich immun sind
mehr freiheiten ermöglichen das ziel
dessen ist dass wir nicht im dauer
lockdown verharren wollen sondern dass
wir endlich wieder innerhalb europas
frei reisen können ganz gleich ob
geschäftlich oder als urlaub
voraussetzung dafür dass der impfstoff
schneller als bisher produziert und
verkauft wird und damit wären wir wieder
beim anfang
ja handel gellinek beobachtet diesen
gipfel für uns alle auch frau merkel ist
jetzt also für einen impfpass klingt ja
fast so als sei man sich da einig
geworden
ja man ist sich einig geworden auf dem
eu gipfel allerdings hat man sich nur
auf eine rein technische lösung geeinigt
ja es soll eine impf abgeben in der
eingetragen werden kann ob man geimpft
ist oder nicht oder ob man vielleicht
auch immun ist nach einer kur wird
erkrankung aber wie gesagt es geht nur
darum dass man eine app hat die in allen
mitgliedstaaten technisch funktioniert
die miteinander kommuniziert und dafür
hat man sich drei monate zeit gegeben
das verdeckt aber den streit der
dahinter steht nämlich was man welche
rechte man mit dieser app verbindet und
dieser streit geht in vollem umfang
weiter spanier und griechen stellen sich
vor dass man damit hotels und flüge
buchen kann und eben urlaub in ihren
ländern machen die deutschen sind hat
deutlich skeptischer ob man mit einer
impfung eben solche reise privilegien
verbinden kann
der streit geht also weiter zunächst mal
wer ist ja auch ganz schön wenn
überhaupt erst mal genug geimpft würde
welche erkenntnisse hast oder von diesem
gipfel mitgenommen es war sehr
interessant auf dem gipfel haben also
alle staats und regierungschefs alle 27
gefordert dass man jetzt aber wirklich
mal die impfstoffproduktion massiv
steigern müsste während zeitgleich
einige hundert meter weiter im europa
parlament ebenfalls virtuell die
direktorin die chefs aller
impfstoffhersteller zugeschaltet waren
im gesundheitsausschuss und da wurde
klar aus dieser anhörung dass europa
sich sehr wohl noch wird gedulden müssen
die chefs von pfizer von biontech und
von astrazeneca und moderne haben
nämlich berichtet dass die
impfstoffherstellung eben noch sehr in
den anfängen steckt dass es zu wenig
ausgangsstoffe gibt dass die fabriken so
schnell nicht der der produktion
nachkommen werden müssen und dass es
auch nicht helfen wird mehr geld in
diese fabriken zu investieren oder
patente weiterzugeben und daran können
eben auch 27 staats und regierungschefs
hundert meter weiter nichts ändern im
moment dankeschön nach brüssel
welche wirkung die mutanten haben werden
das besorgt jedenfalls auch alle
gleichermaßen unter auf öffnungen
stichwort schulen könnten sich in den
zahlen bemerkbar macht
die zahlen für deutschland sind heute
jedenfalls nicht erfreulich 11.869 neu
gemeldete infektionen das ist ein
anstieg von rund 16 prozent gegenüber
der vorwoche und der höchste tageswert
seit fast drei wochen die zahl der neu
gemeldeten todesfälle ist gott sei dank
nicht auch gleichermaßen gestiegen liegt
aber bei immerhin 385 die vielzitierte
sieben tage incidents liegt im
bundesdurchschnitt bei 61,7 stagnation
mit steigender tendenz so lässt sich das
wohl zusammenfassen
epidemiologen warnen erst steige es
langsam und dann irgendwann mit wucht
jetzt zu schnell zu weit zu öffnen sei
deshalb gefährlich torge bode berichtet
5745 menschen brauchten am dritten
januar intensivmedizinische behandlung
weil sie schwer an cupid 19 erkrankt
waren
heute liegt diese zahl bei 2898 die zahl
hat sich nahezu halbiert der shutdown
hat gewirkt auch im universitätsklinikum
wird ein herr eckel köln
aber die zweite welle ging auch hier
ordentlich an die substanz das was wir
gesehen haben in den letzten wochen und
monaten ist dass das personal extrem
belastet ist sowohl physisch als auch
psychisch bei dem wort lockerungen
schrillen bei intensivmedizinern alle
alarmglocken den shutter und jetzt
aufzugeben wie es die politik gerade
diskutiert sei kaum zu verantworten wenn
wir das aufgeben und wenn wir hier
lücken produzieren
dann werden wir eine dritte welle haben
und dann müssen wir damit rechnen dass
die situation ähnlich wieder eskaliert
wie es im dezember hatten und das
sollten wir tunlichst vermeiden lockern
oder nicht kommt eine dritte welle und
wie heftig würde sie uns treffen
seit beginn der pandemie haben
intensivmediziner daten erhoben und
ausgewertet
entwickelt haben sie daraus ein
prognosemodell dass die auswirkungen
einer möglichen dritten welle berechnen
soll
wir haben dazu verschiedene faktoren
hinzu genommen die häufig ist die
mutation in deutschland vorhanden wie
viele sind hier ebenfalls gehen davon
aus dass die geimpften keinen schweren
intensiver laufen wir haben während der
lebensgefährlich ist und alle diese
faktoren haben jetzt ausgewertet und in
die zukunft geschaut und das ergebnis
impfen wir in dem gleichen tempo weiter
und würde der shutdown ab dem siebten
märz gelockert werden könnte die zahl
der belegten intensivbetten im
schlimmsten fall auf über 25.000 steigen
wird bei gleichbleibendem tempo erst ab
april vorsichtig geöffnet würde die
intensivbetten belegung nur um die 5000
liegen so das rechenmodell das ist eine
große belastung aber das ist eine
machbare herausforderung und wenn wir
dann eben dazu impfen dann sind wir am
ende des dritten quartals glaube ich
dass wir die pandemie bewältigt haben
werden zusammen außerdem plädieren die
intensivmediziner dafür zum dreh
produktionswert den sogenannten erwert
als maßstab für politische
entscheidungen zurückzukehren
der re produktionswert ermöglicht uns
die auswirkungen der maßnahmen sehr
schnell zu beurteilen wenn wir zum
beispiel zu schnell geöffnet haben zu
viel erlaubt haben steigt dieser sehr
schnell an und dann wissen wir dass wir
zu weit gegangen sind weil dann beginnt
das exponentielle wachstum und dann
müssen wir gegen maßnahmen treffen
die mediziner haben heute nur
verschiedene mögliche szenarien
vorgestellt ob sie ein treffen oder
nicht hängt vom verhalten jedes
einzelnen und politischen entscheidungen
ab und als gäbe es in dieser ganzen
problematik nicht schon genug sorgen und
auch genug druck der auf allen politisch
verantwortlichen lastet kam dann heute
noch eine meldung hinzu die nicht nur in
berlin für offene münder sorgte georg
nüßlein gesundheitsexperte der csu
und stellvertretender fraktionschef der
unionsparteien steht unter
korruptionsverdacht ausgerechnet in
verbindung mit dem ankauf von
atemschutzmasken
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt mehr zu
den hintergründen von unserem
korrespondenten klasse münsterhausen
bayerisches schwaben fahnder durchsuchen
das wohnhaus des abgeordneten nüßlein
unmittelbar nach der aufhebung von
dessen immunität der mann mit der maske
und das mögliche geschäft mit den masken
sollte sich der vorwurf bestätigen der
politische schaden wäre enorm
man muss sich das vorstellen ein
führender gesundheitspolitiker der cdu
csu bereichert sich bei der masken
beschaffung seiner eigenen regierung
also wenn sich diese vorwürfe erhärten
dann muss das natürlich massive
konsequenzen an
660.000 euro soll das 9 für die
vermittlung eines masken herstellers
weil die gesundheitsministerien in
bayern und im bund in rechnung gestellt
haben
die csu im bundestag meist auf die
unschuldsvermutung zugunsten
verdächtiger hin alle anderen fraktionen
tun dies heute auch sie aber fordern
endlich ein lobbyregister das was wir
bisher wissen ist definitiv kein
kavaliersdelikt und von daher muss jetzt
umfassend aufgeklärt werden und wir
verlangen auch gleichzeitig dass wir
endlich voran kann bei den themen mehr
transparenz politisch wird es aber
natürlich ein schlechtes licht auf das
parlament und deshalb sollten wir jetzt
unsere transparenz anstrengungen
verstärken etwa mit einem hobby
transparenzgesetz die cdu csu muss ihre
blockade auflösen für mehr transparenz
wir brauchen mehr transparenz
nachvollziehbarkeit und offenlegung
bislang bremste die union solche
bestrebungen
dabei gerät mit nüssen nach karin strenz
und philipp amthor nun schon das dritte
fraktionsmitglied in die schlagzeilen
die cdu csu fraktion das ist ja die
fraktion die in dieser legislaturperiode
da wirklich schwer verhaltensauffällig
sind ich erinnere an frau strenz an
herrn am tor und nun ein fall der noch
nicht geklärt ist deswegen will ich dem
nicht vorgreifen
und deswegen ist natürlich die cdu/csu
in besonderer weise gefragt insgesamt 13
objekte wurden heute durchsucht in
deutschland und in liechtenstein
viel arbeit für die ermittler und jetzt
erstmal hans wolf mit den nachrichten da
gibt es auch erst noch mal um die korona
lage in europa in frankreich hat sich
nach den worten von premierminister kast
ex die gesundheitslage in den letzten
tagen verschlechtert für mehrere
regionen wurde eine erhöhte warnstufe
ausgerufen kaarst kündigte an dass dort
nun verschärfte maßnahmen geprüft würden
gestern seien zum ersten mal seit
november wieder mehr als 30.000 neuen
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden
gemeldet worden
der mindestlohn in der altenpflege wird
in den kommenden zweieinhalb jahren
voraussichtlich nicht um 25 prozent
angehoben
entsprechende pläne die das
bundesarbeitsministerium unterstützt
sind gescheitert grund ist die ablehnung
durch den katholischen wohlfahrtsverband
caritas seine zustimmung als einer der
großen träger der altenpflege wäre laut
gesetz nötig gewesen um den geplanten
tarifvertrag bundesweit verbindlich zu
machen
gewerkschaften reagierten enttäuscht
arbeitgeberverbände und privaten
pflegeanbieter begrüßten die
entscheidung
die bundesanwaltschaft hat wegen des
verdachts auf geheimdienstliche
agententätigkeit anklage gegen einen
mann erhoben der dem russischen
geheimdienst sensible daten über
bundestagsgebäude weitergegeben haben
soll
der 55 jährige habe aus eigenem antrieb
gehandelt und sei nicht vom russischen
geheimdienst angeworben worden die seine
tätigkeit für eine firma die mit der
betriebssicherheit elektrische geräte
befasst war habe er zugang zu dateien
mit den grundrissen der bundestags
liegenschaften gehabt und sich mitte
2017 entschlossen die daten
weiterzugeben
mit einer groß angelegten razzia ist die
polizei in berlin und brandenburg gegen
eine radikal islamistische vereinigung
vorgegangen und 850 beamte durchsuchten
wohnungen und andere räume die aktion
richtete sich gegen eine etwa 20-köpfige
gruppierung die verboten wurde
die behörden werfen der vereinigung vor
terroranschläge zu propagieren und stark
antisemitisch ausgerichtet zu sein
drei tage lang haben die deutschen
bischöfe bei ihrer
frühjahrsvollversammlung getagt
mitten unter ihnen wenngleich eine
virtuell der kölner kardinal rainer
maria bild der weiter ein gutachten
zurück hält das den umgang mit sexuellem
missbrauch in seinem bistum untersucht
wie viele menschen tatsächlich wegen
dieses themas die kirche verlassen lässt
sich noch nicht beziffern aber speziell
im erzbistum köln gibt es deutliche
anzeichen für eine hohe akute
austrittswelle
wegen der großen nachfrage nach terminen
für kirchenaustritte der letzte woche
sogar der server des amtsgerichts köln
wegen überlastung zusammengebrochen
rund 5000 menschen sollen gleichzeitig
versucht haben einen termin zu bekommen
ina baltes hat mit zwei kölner
katholiken über ihre beweggründe
gesprochen zu bleiben oder zu gehen nele
jacobs ist raus aus der kirche und
irgendwie ein typischer fall
die studentin ist katholisch
aufgewachsen aber jetzt ist ihr die
kirche fremd geworden
der fall wilkie hat einen langen
denkprozess nun besiegelt es gab in der
vergangenheit schon immer wieder
verschiedene situationen in denen ich
nicht zufrieden war mit der institution
aber dieser fall ist irgendwie ein sehr
sehr schwerwiegendes beispiel eigentlich
dafür was falsch ist mit der
katholischen kirche und der mich
letztendlich dazu gebracht hat
auszutreten damit folgt sie einem
rasanten trend 216.000 kirchenaustritte
waren ist 2018 ein jahr später 273.000
ein thema das die bischofskonferenz
heute überschattet jeder kirchenaustritt
tut weh und wir nehmen ihn war als eine
reaktion auf ein skandalöses bild der
kirche dass wir derzeit abgeben und
sicherlich gibt es manches im erzbistum
köln dazu zu klären aber allein den
fokus auf den erzbischof von köln zu
richten
das wäre doch kurz schlüssig auch lothar
schröder ist entsetzt über den fall
wirkt aber er will bleiben jetzt erst
recht austritt ist keine option
der glaube so sagt er gebe ihm
geplanten fürs leben kirche ist ja kein
fußballverein aus den austritt weiland
der präsident nicht passt oder weil
einem der trainer nicht passt und kirche
ist eben nicht der bischof kirche ist
nicht der erzbischof kirche ist nicht
der kardinal und auch nicht der papst
sondern kirche ist die gemeinschaft der
gläubigen diese gemeinschaft christliche
feiern und die karitative arbeit der
kirche das so sagen experten lässt
bisher noch 22,6 millionen katholiken in
der kirche verbleiben das ist rund jeder
vierte deutsche
doch der umgang woelkis mit möglichem
missbrauch wirkten wie der tropfen der
das fass zum überlaufen bringt austritt
das ist nicht mehr bloß steuern sparen
sondern jetzt auch ein signal das was
die kirche uns in den letzten jahren
gezeigt hat vor allen dingen
stellvertretend dafür das erzbistum köln
und rainer maria woelki
das ist nicht das ist nicht das was
vielleicht jesus einmal gepredigt hat
also das ist nicht das was die zehn
gebote sagen das ist nicht das was
kirche eigentlich sein sollte das image
problem der kirche wächst denn die
bischofskonferenz hat einmal mehr
offenbart aller aufklärung läuft noch
immer
holprig und langsam zeit die die
katholische kirche in deutschland nicht
mehr hat und dabei gäbe es genug andere
lebens themen bei denen sich nach wie
vor viele menschen kirchlichen
seelsorgerischen beistand wünschen und
ihn aufsuchen
beim großen thema sterbehilfe etwa da
sind sich katholische und evangelische
kirche einig zumindest auf der
führungsebene und vertreten ihre
position auch gemeinsam sterbebegleitung
also justiz und palliativmedizin fördern
ja assistierte sterbehilfe nein die
gegenpositionen dieser schwierigen
gesellschaftspolitischen debatte ist die
förderung nach selbstbestimmten sterben
sie wurde vor einem jahr durch ein
weitreichendes und aufsehenerregendes
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
gestärkt die sterbehilfe muss gesetzlich
neu geregelt werden
das war der auftrag der richter an die
politik doch was ist seitdem geschehen
der frage ist christoph schneider nach
eigentlich könnte helmut feldmann
zufrieden sein
vergangenes jahr war seine
verfassungsbeschwerde erfolgreich das
verbot der geschäftsmäßigen sterbehilfe
wurde gekippt er könnte sollte sich
seine unheilbare lungenkrankheit copd
verschlimmern ein tödliches medikament
bekommen doch fällt man ist unzufrieden
das ist menschenunwürdig das spürt sich
nicht mehr in meinem wagen der humanität
ab weil das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
anordnungen gegeben dass schnellstens
die politik aktiv werden muss das
bundesverfassungsgericht definierte vor
einem jahr erstmals ein recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben und dieses
recht sei nicht beschränkt auf unheilbar
erkrankte sondern gelte für alle phasen
des lebens doch wie kann das geregelt
werden
seit vergangenem sommer liegen im
bundesgesundheitsministerium mehr als 50
stellungnahmen von kirchen verbänden
sozialen organisationen vor doch bislang
gibt es dort nur einen hausinternen
arbeitsentwurf kathrin helling klar fdp
politikerin hat zusammen mit spd und
linken ein gesetzentwurf auf den weg
gebracht für das recht auf
selbstbestimmtes sterben
dieses recht gilt es auf der einen seite
zu gewährleisten auf der anderen seite
aber auch abzusichern
zur absicherung haben wir bestimmte
schutzmaßnahmen vorgesehen wir möchten
mit diesen niedrigschwelligen
bundesweiten beratungsstellen angebot
das wir vor sehen wo jeder tatsächlich
soll auch aufsuchende beratung
beispielsweise geben für personen die
etwa in pflegeheimen leben mit diesen
beratungsstellen angebot wollen wir
jedem wirklich zugang zu umfassender
hilfe gewährleisten für den cdu
abgeordneten michael brandt der einst
für das verbot der geschäftsmäßigen
sterbehilfe eintrat muss die diskussion
sorgfältiger geführt werden
es braucht auch eine gesellschaftliche
debatte viele im parlament und außerhalb
des parlamentes sind der auffassung dass
der suizid nicht zu einer gewöhnlichen
option werden darf neben anderen
ärztlichen behandlungen quasi mit einem
staatlichen siegel und dann auch eine
abrechnungs ziffer bei der krankenkasse
aus sicht des deutschen ethikrats muss
eine neuregelung zwei perspektiven
vereinbaren wichtig ist es tatsächlich
diese balance hinzubekommen dass man auf
der einen seite die selbstbestimmung der
menschen auch am lebensende respektiert
das auch wirklich ernst nimmt
gleichzeitig zugewandte fürsorge
ermöglicht und dann auch noch eine
maßvolle also mit augenmaß gestaltete
suizidprävention umsetzt für das
individuum nicht gegen das individuum
doch die zeit drängt denn im september
wird ein neuer bundestag gewählt der
sich dann völlig neu mit der sterbehilfe
befassen müsste diese zeit haben viele
sterbenskranke nicht mehr würde dass
menschen hier auch dazu dass wenn ein
mensch schwer krank ist und sein leben
beenden möchte hat er die möglichkeit
bekommt das auto auf dem land illegalem
wege zu tun
die gesetzliche neuregelung der
sterbehilfe ist für helmut feldmann
geboten zwar nicht mehr persönlich für
ihn aber für viele andere bleibt ein
schwieriges thema mit nachrichten geht
es jetzt nochmal weiter heinz zunächst
mit dem blick auf die deutsche
wirtschaft nach der neuen gfk
konsumklimastudie gibt es im februar
eine erholung trotz der unsicheren
kroner situation hat sich jede
perspektive der deutschen verbraucher
verbessert frank bethmann gleichzeitig
spricht der handelsverband deutschland
der hde von einer dramatischen situation
viele händler
ja genau was nützt es den ladenbesitzern
werden das gilt zwar wieder lockerer
sitzt aber die geschäfte weiter
geschlossen bleiben
der lobbyverband eben der hde rechnet
heute bereits vor dass rund die hälfte
der unternehmer in diesem jahr in
insolvenzgefahr geraten würden wenn es
nicht weitere staatshilfen gibt ein
einzelhändler aus der nürnberger
innenstadt stellvertretend für
vermutlich viele tausende
andere enormen eine katastrophe wir
haben zwischen 80 und 90 prozent
umsatzeinbruch und wir haben trotzdem
personalkosten da es ist nicht rentabel
der ruf nach öffnungs perspektiven wird
lauter der hde fordert konkret die
öffnung der einzelhandelsgeschäfte ab
dem 8
märz auch gastronomen wollen im
gleichschritt mit den händlern öffnen
der präsident des deutschen städtetages
mahnt dagegen zur vorsicht für
umfassende öffnung sehe er derzeit noch
keinen spielraum
gleichzeitig fordert er finanzhilfen für
die angeschlagenen innenstädte wir
stellen uns dabei 500 millionen euro
jährlich für fünf jahre vor
um nachhaltig etwas zu erreichen die
forderung nach mehr geld für innenstädte
sind nicht neu
es braucht aber auch die richtigen ideen
und konzepte dafür frank wittmann vielen
dank ein ergebnis aus der
fußball-europa-league hoffenheim hat am
abend das zwischenrunden rückspiel gegen
molde fk aus norwegen 0 2 verloren und
damit den einzug ins achtelfinale
verpasst
die nordische skiweltmeisterschaft
findet in diesem jahr in oberstdorf
statt in zwei disziplinen gab es zum
auftakt heute medaillen bei den damen
siegte im klassik sprint die schwedin
jonas und lokalmatadorin laura gimmler
schaffte es ins halbfinale belegte am
ende rang zehn und im sprint der herren
führte langlauf topstar johanneshaus
führt kleine norwegischen dreifach
triumph an
aus über 200 millionen kilometern
entfernung hat uns dieses spektakuläre
panorama bild vom mars erreicht
aufgenommen vom nasa rovers viren zeigt
die aus 142 hochaufgelösten einzelfotos
zusammengesetzte aufnahme geröll hügel
und den horizont rund um einen
ausgetrockneten see in der vergangenen
woche war der forschungsroboter auf dem
mars gelandet er soll dort unter anderem
nach spuren von mikroorganismen suchen
john und yoko princess diana james bond
die briten das muss man ihnen lassen
haben eine ganze menge zeitgenössische
ikonen hervorgebracht die für die ganze
welt stil prägt waren vor allem aber
nicht nur in der musik von pop bis punk
aus swinging london und landet calling
der 60er und 70er wurde später cool
britannia dieser ära widmet sich heute
widmete sich heute eine große auktion in
london zu kaufen war british school so
der titel der ganzen angelegenheit kunst
musik mode vor allem erinnerungen an
glorreiche zeiten vielleicht auch ein
stück britische selbstvergewisserung
vermutet für unser korrespondent andreas
stamm
stil klasse coolness auf weltniveau
die queen und bond bewegung verkörperung
des besten was britannien zu bieten hat
vereint in sprung ins londoner
olympiastadion
der inszenierte eröffnungs gap für die
spiele 2012
diese britische coolness brachte das
auktionshaus bonhams heute unter den
hammer
mehr als 300 exponate die zeigen sollen
woher das great das großartig in great
britain herrührt etwa ein foto der
beatles der musikalischen welt
revolutionäre aus liverpool oder ein
anderes auktions objekt der begierde
kate moss porträt eines der letzten
klassischen supermodels eine sammlung
eine frage wie kann die im weltmaßstab
recht kleine insel internationale kultur
ikonen am fließband produzieren
[Musik]
die briten haben das talent die regeln
auf eine lustige art und weise zu
brechen
vor allem in den swinging sixties der
revolutionären nachkriegsära und dann
wieder in einer explosion der
kreativität in den 90ern nach zwei
wirtschaftlich sehr harten jahrzehnten
neues schaffen wurde zum britischen
markenzeichen und der jungen jack war
als symbol überall was bei der option
namens british school immer mitschwingt
wir haben von vielen das beste
modeschöpferin vivienne westwood und
alexander mcqueen das ein damien hirst
den traum vieler frauen füße manolo
blahniks verzieren und versüßen dürfte
kulturelle weltklasse vor allem in der
inszenierung wie banksy die straßenkunst
des unbekannten provokateurs verzaubert
millionen und bringt millionen
wir versteigern 18 drucke von banksy bei
mädchen der ballons starten wir bei
170000 euro ein großartiges exponat vor
allem das original während einer auktion
2018 von künstler geschreddert wurde bei
der online auktion bringt der
wertvollste banksy am ende rund 220.000
euro 50.000 für kate moss nicht das ganz
große geld im internationalen kunstmarkt
vielleicht so später weil viele der
ikonen in die jahre gekommen sein und
großbritannien aktuell gar nicht mehr so
großartig sei tanja die 90er vorbei als
künstler beim damaligen premier blair
ein und aus gingen nun ist bei exit
wirtschaftskrise schottland will das
königreich verlassen statt
großbritannien stehen die zeichen eher
auf ein jahrzehnt klein england
aber das mit der queen und bunt das
macht ihm keiner nach
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
wetter geht es bei maybrit illner weiter
die sich mit ihren gästen heute auch dem
politischen thema dieser tage mit mit
lockern aber sicher geht das
und um 0 uhr 30 meldet sich dann glückte
mail mit unserem heutigen update
ich habe wieder sehen und wieder sind
[Musik]
meine damen und herren wenn ihnen gerade
etwas in der nase kribbelt dann könnten
das erlen oder haselpollen sein was wir
aber alle merken ist dass die luft sehr
schlecht ist und zwar sehr schlecht vor
allen dingen hier richtung baden
württemberg sehr oft aber auch schlecht
und nur selten gut und die luftqualität
ist deswegen so schlecht weil der
saharastaub inzwischen weit unten
angekommen ist was jetzt helfen würde
ist regen und er kommt in form von einer
kaltfront die hier von nordwesten
heranzieht und bis morgen abend dann
auch süddeutschland erreicht haben wird
sehr viel regen bringt sie nicht mit
aber heute nach regen dass hier zwischen
dem spreewald und dem niederrhein in
süddeutschland es ist zum teil klar und
dort sinken die temperaturen auf plus 1
bis minus 2 grad unter den dichteren
wolken bleibt es bei 8 bis 4 grad milder
und in norddeutschland sind die kalten
temperaturen schon angekommen
designierter 4 bis 2 grad und so bleibt
es auch morgen dort recht kühl mit 8 bis
12 grad
häufig scheint aber hinter dieser
kaltfront auch die sonne bei west
nordwest wind der regen erreicht sachsen
und am nachmittag dann auch
süddeutschland bis zum abend regnet es
auch in der oberpfalz und im
nordschwarzwald südlich der donau aber
da bleibt es morgen wohl bis zum abend
sonnig und trocken und deswegen klettern
dauert die temperaturen noch einmal auf
14 bis 18 grad dann kommt die kaltfront
auch dort an und das ist in den nächsten
tagen deutlich kühler aber doch für die
meisten recht sonnig schönen abend noch